um oh she's coming out let's listen in
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's a legal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth I was
elected by the conservative party with a
mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills on on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though
given the situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you